you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens welcome back to the show
everybody you are watching to our daily
live from the game spot co-op stage here
at e3 2016 I we are here really excited
we just had Tim Schafer on the show yeah
I'm Ashley sky that this is jeff cannata
my co-host yeah i'm happy to be here to
you III it's uh it's great we have an
awesome guest David egg is here oh you
probably know i miss D CH the community
manager for destiny you guys had a big
announcement right before e3 the week
before e3 indeed yeah of a new expansion
called rise of iron right rise of iron
it sounds like it just sounds strong
just sounds really strong sounds regal
well that's the destiny player fantasy
wha ya feel like a badass want to turn
you into a regal heraldic night on a
quest to protect all of humanity from
the dangers that threaten us of course
yeah that's what we're here to talk
about yeah that's denny rise of iron is
a new expansion for destiny something
we're going to unleash this fall in
September 20th all sorts of cool stuff
to do new enemies to fight new places to
explore new weapons and armor to add to
your character new ways to become more
powerful new raid new story new strikes
new bad guys so let's talk about it well
tell me about the new raid I think let's
start at the top yeah it's there to end
game let's go right to end game at the
mountaintop in the summit then just roll
down and so the raid is in the minds of
many players of Destiny sort of the
pinnacle of the experience you know it's
the end game it's the culmination of the
story it's when you finally infiltrate
that enemy stronghold and destroy the
source of their power once and for all
it's the most challenging activities
that we provide in destiny you need a
fireteam you need six players who agree
to work with each other to communicate
with each other to see the experience
through to the end and and you all have
sweet Lutz they all have a sweet look at
us balance yeah yeah you gotta go in you
got to be powerful you want to bring
your best game and the more you play the
raid the more we give you even more
sweet Lutz
so people start to actually sort of bear
the trophies of their enemy you know as
things that they can wear and equip and
shoot we have a new enemy to fight in
the form of a new house of ballin so we
got the Fallen devil splicers they've
discovered a horrible technological
plague they burrow deep into the Golden
Age vaults deep beneath old Russia and
Unleashed this technological plague that
they can use to transform their minds
and their bodies and become machine gods
so we have to band together under the
command of Lord Saladin indeed the sole
surviving iron Lord is calling all of
the Guardians to rally to his iron
banner and to go out and fight these new
bad guys and there's some of that action
right there are those you may see wolves
is that necessary thank you wool oh hey
morning they're imported wool reported
those are Lord Saladin's wolves okay
excellent so what are your coms baseball
miss space log everything there in space
now so they're in space so which makes
them now spaceballs yeah uh so tell us a
little bit about interacting with the
community I mean destiny has a really
passionate fan base really passionate
fan base they love the game they're
really into it I see memes about destiny
still at me it's been almost what two
years after launch like it's been a
while no I still see destiny memes
people are still talking about it in
terms of developing expansions how much
does how much does the development of an
expansion rely on a player feedback like
how in terms of percentages I mean
obviously development is you know hey
guys like with this what we're doing but
you go into the community what kinds of
feedback do you really take from the
players all kinds of feedback we have
monitors mounted to the wall at bungie
and we are watching people streaming
gameplay from the world of our game all
day long so you know you walk through
the studio and you see different people
playing different activities we're
always connected to the player with
destiny it's always online so we're
connected to every single player you
don't need to be a streamer to get our
attention or to influence our creative
process we have so many different data
points we can rely on to make a great
game and to bring new things to life you
know like the heroes and the adventures
in right
of iron you know we have you know the
activities people that play the weapons
that they equip you know the the
anecdotal feedback that comes from forms
the conversations the things that people
say about the game the ways in which
they wanted to change the ways in which
they think it can be better then there
is you know our own gameplay I mean so
many people at bungie also play destiny
so our own experiences shaped this a lot
too we see the YouTube videos that they
create you know me we we celebrate fan
created content every day every week at
bunging and I mean they're the main
characters in our world and while the
developers in the creators at bungie do
have their own sparks of inspiration
they have their own creative ideas
knowing your audience and being inspired
by your audience is a huge part of that
and when we were creating destiny we
were doing it very much in a vacuum we
had this new thing new to us you know as
a very ambitious project for bungee and
we unleash that under the world and then
began the process of getting acquainted
with this new audience that was playing
our game and letting them really inform
us as to what that experience was and
then learning how we can better serve
them as entertainers because that's our
goal yeah and what's us so just out of
curiosity what's the most you got the
monitors up on the walls they're
watching people play what's the most
unorthodox play style or choice that
you've maybe seen a player I decide to
go for sure on the week dude we've been
seen people do everything from play
raids blindfolded Oh take more tactical
cues from their opponents you know like
literally going in blind I can do that
except do it right just like challenge
accepted yeah I mean people play through
player activities where they're forced
to equip any loot that drops right at
that moment you know so that the player
experience is very different by the end
of the game we've seen people play
hide-and-go-seek we've seen people you
know sort of have challenges to each
other you know I dare you let's all go
in and let's play this game together I
have some friends who actually go in and
they equip an exotic sniper rifle that's
very hard to use they say we're all
going in we're going to use nothing but
no land beyond and we're going to see
who can score the most kills by the end
of this crucible match so there's so
many different ways to play the game
there are so many different options that
you get to embrace as a player what are
you going to wear what class are you
going to play as
what weapons are you going to equip so
people can play destiny in different
ways over and over and over again yeah I
mean the most hardcore people in our
community say I've one of each live
hunter x warlock and every perk set
every gear you know every tactical
advantage you know and they just mix and
match all that stuff together until they
create their own personal ultimate
badass so we we've heard that this might
be the last paid expansion for destiny
one is that true I can't confirm or deny
anything about the future of Destiny
other than the fact that rides of iron
is the future of destiny septembrie ah
the immediate future of destiny is sep
tember 20th and we have rise of iron
we're going to be sending you into a
known you've never explored before the
plague lands is where you'll find the
Fallen double splicers you are going to
redeem the sacrifice that was made by
the iron Lords to contain that
technological plague in the first place
we're gonna honor their memory we're
going to ascend to their ranks we're
gonna become powerful in some new and
exciting ways and we're gonna save the
world can you tease some of those sweet
lutz for us I know that you know destiny
has evolved so much since launch and
even the whole way the loot system works
has been completely changing I think in
a month for the better you know having
yo share a specific piece that
influences my play style and lets me
break the rules and really fun ways yes
is awesome are there some notable things
that you are revealing about rise of
iron well we have new gear sets that
will commemorate the different things
that you've done I think people have
felt about destiny in the past that the
only way to become all-powerful and
destiny is to play the rain that's
really no longer the case if you're a
crucible person if you love the story if
you love patrolling the world and
participating in public events if you
like the rituals that define the player
experience if you like the raids there
are many different ways to become
powerful and destiny so all of that gear
satisfies that desire to evolve and to
become you know the the apex predator on
your friends list yeah yeah a lot of the
new gear and a lot of the new armor
that's going you're going to find in
Rajab iron has some interesting new
perks sets some different ways to
influence combat and change the sandbox
and to change the way you fight so there
will be some new things for you to
discover as a player and that's part of
the fun is to get a new piece of gear
you know to put on
that new helmet and say this gives me
something new this enables me to do
something I've never done before right
and play behind phone with my blindfold
yeah of course yeah that's now my new
goal Hawaii blindness sure it's the
blast shield down I can't even see you
don't need the blast shield like a boy I
need that behind your feelings so what
do you play as in destiny I am a warlock
this was an incredibly emotional
decision I'm as emotional it's so
emotional for everybody I know that
feeling I just I saw wizard robes and I
said I want to be that guy like well
maybe you should play the game first and
really understand I'm like no no I will
adopt to a fighting style that
complements those yeah I will find a way
what am i doing Romeo saying why should
be yes no and I love that about destiny
because I feel like not that it's a loot
driven game but obviously in any MMO
where you are rating and doing a lot of
these sort of high-end and get things
loot obviously plays a huge part of that
yeah and I think that that's such a cool
thing about games like destiny and
destiny itself that you can look at
somebody in a video or on a stream and
you could say well I just want to be
that guy like what I don't even care
what class it is I'll figure it out I
just want to wear that helmet or carry
that gun or you know where those robes
or whatever that is like that's such a
cool part of destiny and I always felt
that the character design of destiny is
always so fun but also like you said so
badass like you just feel cool and you
want to look at pictures of you and take
like pictures of yourself and share them
with your friends and everything and I
think that's really contributed to the
way the community has grown without a
doubt we love we have art galleries up
on bungie.net you know our headquarters
on the internet where every day we're
posting new fan art you know they upload
that stuff we approve it so if you're
making cool destiny art please throw it
at us you know share it with us on our
website we even got around recently to
deactivating the the user interface and
the heads-up display so you can just get
a nice clean image of the world take
green shots I mean what's a what's a
video game with amazing art if you can't
take a selfie well now let's trim now I
don't want to play blindfolded no guys
are giving me conflicting up a fight
blindfolded and then you take your pick
we leave that to the one percentage
definitely want to see the art and
that's one of the things we wanted to do
is is to really create a player fantasy
we think destiny is a game that's driven
by action but rewarded by louth so it's
supposed to be a game that's fun to play
you know you see the world through the
eyes of the hero you know you walk in
the footsteps of the character that you
create but if you're brave and if you
defeat your enemies and complete your
missions that gear though that weapon
those weapons in that armor really
defines you and the things that you've
enjoyed doing so people can add a glance
tell what someone's into and I think one
of the best and most meaningful
questions in the destiny community is
from what someone to say where'd you get
that yeah and now this person becomes an
aspirational figure and they can say and
I will take you along and this activity
me and my clan need people like you to
get stuff like this so come with me and
we'll complete this experience for each
other because that's the thing about
destiny it's enjoyed with new people
yeah absolutely so what what is your
favorite aspect of rise of iron what is
that what is the most exciting new piece
for you I love jumping on my Sparrow and
exploring a place I've never been we had
a studio wide play test right on Friday
everybody at bungee puts down you know
what they're doing they prop a new build
of the game we all play the game so we
understand what we're making we
understand what we need to do to make an
experience worthy of our players between
now and this fall so you get to a point
where you've completed a story mission
there's no immediate threat you jump
aboard your personal vehicle and you
just wander around you see what's out
there you know and the plague lens is
such an interesting place you know it's
forever transformed by this
technological plague the seva that i
keep you know hinting at me alluding to
and there's some interesting new ways to
patrol there's interesting public events
you never know what's going to happen
when you're just out in the world of
destiny what moments of action are going
to erupt in that landscape who you might
encounter who might team up with you for
a moment of action that you know you
need to work together to overcome what
sort of rewards you might get for doing
that so that's been really the freeform
aspects of the game or something that I
enjoy but the same time I mean like with
my clan you know we play crucible we
play the raids we play the strikes you
know we play the story missions we play
all of the things that you'll find more
of an right
of iron so no matter what sort of player
you are no matter what every specific
answer to that question is we're giving
them more of that in this expansion
sounds exciting acts coming out this
fall yep sep tember 20th all right xbox
one playstation 4 def your iDevice
definitely your eyes of iron I thank you
so much if you guys are just tuning in
you didn't catch us at the beginning
this is deej community manager for
bungee and destiny thank you so much for
stopping by watch we really appreciate
it we will be right back with the one
and only victor Lucas yeah finding a
sign about III in general don't touch
that dial